جاسوس من بين جواسيس كثر عرفهم التاريخ
ولكنه الاكثر شهره في تاريخ المانيا
الشرقيه كيف لا وهو بطل فضيحه جيوم التي
اسفرت عن استقاله المستشار الفيدرالي
والبراند وتسببت في يوم اسود بتاريخ
الالمان انه جانتا ريو احد اهم جواسيس
فتره ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه فما
قصته ولد جانتر كارل هاينغيوم في برلين
عام
ونشا في حي برينز لاوربيرج الذي سكنه في
الغالب ابناء الطبقه العامله عندما كان في
السابعه عشره التحق بالقوات المسلحه
الالمانيه حيث شهد نهايه الحرب في
الدنمارك كما تعرض للاسر من قبل
البريطانيين قبل ان تتم اعادته الى برلين
الشرقيه في برلين وفي جمهوريه المانيا
الديمقراطيه كانت وزاره الدوله تبحث عن
اشخاص للتجنيد شريطه ان يكونوا بلا اقارب
ومن الطبقه العامله فاستقطبوا واخضعوه
لدورات تدريب على التجسس كذلك كان الحال
مع المراه التي اختارها للزواج كريستيل
التي كبرت بلا اب حيث التقطتها الوزاره
واصبحت تعمل فيها كاتبه طابعه ثم سكرتيره
خلال تلك الفتره عملت يوم مصورا
الفوتوغرافيا ثم موظفا في دار للنشر اسندت
للزوجين مهمه تقصي معلومات حول الحزب
الاشتراكي الديمقراطي وبناء على ذلك تم
تامين سفرهما الى فرانكفورت في عام
1956 كلاجئين
حصلت كريستيل على سمي هاينز بما اصبح اسمه
غيوم المستعار هانسن وعمل الزوجان في
البدايه باداره مقهى قبل ان تنضم كريستيل
للحزب الاشتراكي الديمقراطي وتصبح سكرتيره
في مستشاريه ولايه لاحقا انضمت
وبدا يشق طريقه في صفوف الحزب حسب
التعليمات
لكنما ساعده على الترقيه نجاح الحمله
الانتخابيه التي ادارها لوزير النقل
الاتحادي جورج ليبر حيث تم بعدها تعيينه
في المستشاريه الفيدراليه ليصبح في عام
مستشارا لدى المستشار الفيدرالي والبرراند
في مدينه بول تولى جيوما الاتصالات
والعلاقات العامه للحزب وبات يرافق براند
في الحملات الانتخابيه ورحلات تقص الحقائق
كذلك سمح له موقعه هذا بالوصول الى
الملفات السريه والمناقش في الدائره
الداخليه للمستشار الاتحادي فسرب الكثير
من الوثائق لالمانيا الغربيه كان جيون
مقربا من براند لدرجه انه اصطحبه معه في
رحله اجازه الى النرويج خلال تلك الرحله
ملا اجيوم حقيبه كامله بوثائق سريه بما في
ذلك رسائل الى المستشار من الرئيس ريتشارد
نيكسون حول الاستراتيجيه النوويه لحلف
الناتو ونقلها الى جهه اتصال من المانيا
الشرقيه في السويد في طريق عودته الى
مدينه بول كانت لدى اجهزه الامنيان ذاك
معلومات تشير الى انه قد يكون عميلا
شيوعيا لكنها لم تتبعها حتى عام
1973 في صبيحه يوم الرابع والعشرين من
ابريل عام
1974 حاصر ضباط الشرطه منزل جيوم ببنادق
رشاشه واعتقل الزوجان حيث بانه ضابط لدى
جمهوريه المانيا الديمقراطيه شكلت خيانه
غيوم اكبر فضيحه في تاريخ المانيا الشرقيه
في فتره ما بعد الحرب الالمانيه فقد وصل
عميل وزاره الامن الداخليه للبانيا
الديمقراطيه الى غرفه السلطه في السادس من
مايو وعلى اثر الفضيحه تقدم ويلي براند
باستقالته من منصب المستشار الاتحادي في
خطوه اعتبرها ضروريه احتراما لتاريخه
وللحزب فيما اعتبرت استقاله براند نكسه
لسياسه الجديده بجمهوريه المانيا
الديمقراطيه التي كانت تتبعها منذ اوائل
السبعينيات كما كانت بمثابه يوم اسود
للعديد من الالمان لان ويلي براند بسياسته
مثل حقبه جديده من السلام والمصالحه في
اوروبا
حكم على جيون بالسجن 13 عاما وعلى زوجته
بثمان سنوات
لكنهما سرح في عام
1981 في اطار صفقه تبادل بين الالمانيتين
ثم عاد الى جمهوريه المانيا ديمقراطيه
وانفصل في العام نفسه تزوج جيوم مره اخرى
لكنه عانى في السنوات الاخيره من تدهور
صحته قبل وفاته في عام
1995 كان جيوم قد منح وسام كارل ماركس من
قبل اريك هونيكر الزعيم الشيوعي لالمانيا
الشرقيه كما شكلت سيرته مصدر الهام للعديد
من الاعمال الفنيه في المانيا وبريطانيا
كانت من ابرزها مسرحيه مايكل فراين
الديمقراطيه